hallo leute ich bin kari und hinter der
kamera seht ihr ja normalerweise machen
wir beide videos in berlin und helfen
menschen beim deutsch lernen und zwar
auf unseren kanal wie sie german heute
sind wir allerdings zu gast hier in
zürich und sind auch zu gast auf diesem
kanal und besuchen die halo deutsche
schule in diesem in dieser woche machen
wir eine kleine kooperation und unser
erster schritt ist dass wir uns jetzt
mal die halo deutsche schule ansehen
hallo deutsch schule deutsch lernen mit
spaß
naja du fühlst du dich schon wieder an
die schulzeit erinnert ja und was ihr
nicht erinnert werden
das ist genau die richtige stimmung
wir waren das damals alles durch zur
schule gegangen bist und deutsch gelernt
hat er war sehr entspannt und angenehm
ich habe das richtig genutzt wie lange
hast du dein deutsch kurs gemacht
acht monate war und dann noch kommt es
zu fließend deutsch
nee ich war ich für einen spitzen der
ich brauchte mehr zeit am anfang
überhaupt anzufangen nicht langsam leder
für alle anderen um mich herum sprachen
deutsch und ich dachte ich bin irgendwie
nicht wirklich begabt so dritter stock
hier ist die halle deutsch oder wir
gehen mal rein
als erstes sind wir hier im sekretariat
der schule hier abi thalia und meine
erste frage wäre welche kurse kann man
denn bei euch machen
wir haben drei verschiedene kurs arten
intensivkurse finden täglich zwei
stunden statt sem intensivkurse sind
zwei mal die woche abends und samstags
kurse finden jeden samstag morgen statt
und wir haben ganz verschiedene
kursniveaus angefangen bei den anfängern
11 und sehr fortgeschritten bist du dann
schon mit ca 13 also alle niveaus dabei
jetzt habe ich noch eine spezielle frage
unterrichtet ihr dann hochdeutsch oder
schweizerdeutsch und kann ich bei euch
auch schweizerdeutsch lernen weil das
kann ich ja gerne
als deutsche wir sind nur eine
hochdeutsch schule aber ich kann jetzt
uns gerne ein paar wörter beibringen zum
beispiel hässlich muss jeder wissen
jeder kennen der schweiz
das heißt das denn für ashley ist ein
küchen kasten und hat so viele chs dass
man das einfach keiner aussprechen kann
hier dürfen wir mal in eine klasse
reingucken das ist eine art 2 klasse
gleise ja
so jetzt sind wir hier unten im
erdgeschoss hier gibt es noch ein
weiteres stockwerk der halo deutsche
schule und hier werden wir uns jetzt
auch ein paar schulklassen angucken
hier ist natürlich schon ganz groß
romanisch fotos von den ausflügen der
halo deutsche schule
okay wir sind jetzt eingeladen in eine
schulklasse mit dir hier in der klasse
geht es gerade um die deutschen fälle
domina tief akkusativ dativ die schüler
haben hier gerade kleine gruppen
gebildet und machen jetzt übungen wo sie
sich gegenseitig abfragen müssen und
dann testen ob sie die deutschen fälle
schon richtig benutzen können
[Musik]
das hast du dich gerade in deine eigene
schulzeit erinnert der total
wir haben jetzt hier eine schülerin aus
dem deutschkurs in ihrer pause getroffen
wie heißt du ich heiße sie erinnern
lena ja genau und wo er kanzlerin
freundlich aus russland aber trotzdem
ich auch mal einen französischen akzent
weil ich in paris gewonnen habe ich
diesen aktien behalten
und was machst du jetzt in der schweiz
ich wohne ja in diesen deutsch
sprechenden teilung nicht mal die
schweiz und deswegen bin ich bin ich
hier ein hallo deutsch schule weil ich
einfach deutsch studieren und dann ja
deswegen in welcher stufe bist du jetzt
oder in welchem niveau
im moment habe ich das c1 niveau ja das
ist ja schon dass das top niveau
und wie viele leute seid ihr in eurer
klasse ich glaube etwa sieben oder acht
oder das ist eine ganz kleine klasse ja
es ist wirklich schön weil alle genug
aufmerksamkeit
und man kann auch viel zeit mit sprechen
verbringen wahrscheinlich ja stimmt alle
haben eine gewisse zeit um zu sprechen
alles zu erzählen
das ist wirklich und wie was gefällt dir
hier am unterricht und der ist gefüllt
mir die spaß die lehrenden immer mit
spaß und also die lehrerin auch gut und
gibt uns manchmal die hausaufgaben hilft
uns bereich und ich bin der das hier
sehr gut und lehrern immer weiter und
der manchmal schwierigkeit und manchmal
nicht da war trotzdem wir schaffen
irgendwann und wie gefällt dir die
schule hier
ich bin der halle durch schüler ein die
beste und das gefällt mir
wir haben jetzt beim jazz ska getroffen
sie ist mitglied der schulleitung
hierbei der halo deutsch schule und wir
möchten jetzt gerne von dir wissen was
macht denn die halo deutsch schule aus
jemand der hier hinkommt und hier einen
deutschkurs machen will
was sollte der wissen ja ich denke man
auch wenn man schon in der rezeption
kommt man merkt dass die atmosphäre sehr
schön ist wir sind da eine familiäre
schule noch also sehr klein nicht mehr
so klein wie am anfang da kannte man
jeden schüler noch per name und also das
ist nicht immer schön die atmosphäre die
schüler fühlen sich wohl bei uns wir
haben sehr tolle lehrer die das wirklich
auch in einem ausflug dann auch noch
ausbauen diese super stimmung und bei
uns lernt man wirklich zu sprechen das
ist so ich denke mal das ist ein
markenzeichen unserer schule die schüler
lernen hier im unterricht die sprache
auch anzuwenden nicht nur theoretisch
und das denke ich schon so ein
markenzeichen von uns dass man hier
rauskommt und spricht ancicka wenn man
hier in der schweiz deutsch lernt lernt
man dann schweizerdeutsch oder
hochdeutsch
also wenn du in der schule deutschlands
ganz klar hochdeutsch
wenn du jetzt aber keine schule besucht
dann auf der straße wirst du nur
schweizer deutsch lernen
okay was ist ja für mich ein guter
moment jetzt mal
ein paar sätze zu lernen ich bin ja
jetzt hier ich komme aus deutschland
ich verstehe schweizerdeutsch gar nicht
so gut und sprechen kann ich gar nichts
hast du dann ein paar sätze für mich ja
klar gerne also zuerst werden wir mal an
mit dem wie der grußformel also das ist
das was die deutschen eigentlich am
schwierigsten finden sie probieren es
wohl immer wieder und viele benutzten
sie auch aber es kommt irgendwie ein
bisschen nicht ganz authentisch rüber
wer mal gut sie miteinander bei dir
klingt das sehr gut klingt das dann
nicht authentisch wenn das in
deutschland sagt das hat dann der 30
klingt super passant kam zu einem grüezi
oder ein grüner tee ein
die irgendwie betonen dass falls das ist
das große kommt am meisten
das ist rät siebenand grid ernannt du
siehst du das machst du sehr gut ja also
bin ich schon bisschen authentischer was
sehr gut ja nicht so ganz deutlich hier
mit dieser grußformel schweiz ring durch
dankeschön dann nicht willst du noch was
andere gerne ja dass ich dann sonst kann
ich ja nur hallo sagen kritiker wenn du
mal fragen ist wie es geht also das ist
schon ein bisschen slang wie hessisches
wir sind genau wie hast du es wäre das
auf deutsch wie hashes wie hätte es die
antwort ist dann gut messi gut oder gut
danke merci
[Gelächter]
okay jetzt kann ich schon was ich glaube
sein gretchen miteinander wie pages
das klingt gut also ich find es ging
das war unser kleiner bericht aus der
halo deutsche schule hier in zürich und
wenn ihr deutsch lernen wollt und hier
in der schweiz seit dann kommt doch mal
hier vorbei in die halle deutsche schule
in der fabrikstraße 10 in zürich und
vielleicht macht ihr auch mal ein
deutschkurs hier
und wenn ihr lust habt ein bisschen mehr
über die dialekte zu erfahren die hier
in der schweiz gesprochen werden
dann könnt ihr unsere videos sehen die
wir auf dem easy german kann
zusammen mit der halle deutsche schule
gemacht haben die verlinken wir euch
hier unten danke fürs zu sehen und bis
bald
pure rechtler schon gar nicht so
schlecht recht hoch ashley cole wrestler
[Musik]